was lucky to survive being shot in the
stomach by a policeman the bullet also
fractured his arm he says he was
targeted last year on his way home
because of his work as a news cameraman
for this tv station called gupjug which
is known for broadcasting critical views
of somalia's government
journalists working here say they're
often harassed or targeted somalia
somalia is the worst place to be a
journalist we face too many problems
it's either the government causing
issues or other people
the other people include the armed group
al-shabab which claimed responsibility
for killing the director of state-owned
radio mogadishu five months ago when a
suicide bomber attacked his car
this is what was left of it
abdullah ahmed mumeen leads the somali
journalist syndicate which documents
killings detentions threats and
harassment of journalists he says there
are dozens of cases every year the
national intelligence has been alleged
on serious human rights violations
including abductions killings of
civilians and this is what journalists
are trying to reveal and to report
that's why you see a lot of journalists
are being targeted by the national
intelligence
this radio station called mustac bao
reported when president mohammed
abdullahi farmaja's term ended last year
elections were delayed and he stayed in
office somebody powerful didn't want
presenters to talk about it on air
police raided the station the studio is
behind this door the staff say the
police didn't get through it the
technician says he locked himself inside
and turned off the transmitters
staff say police came in through this
door they rounded up all of the
journalists here took them outside and
took away all of the computers that were
on these desks
bashir mohamed
says while some policemen were breaking
into this cupboard and taking cameras
others beat him with rifle butts and
threatened him
the national intelligence has been
alleged as involved in serious human
rights violations including abductions
killings of civilians and this is what
journalists are trying to reveal that's
why you see a lot of journalists being
targeted
shamaki says after months of requests
police have finally opened the case on
his shooting
the somali journalist syndicate says
it's better than nothing
but that justice for journalists here is
rare
malcolm webb al jazeera mogadishu
somalia